s'il vous plaît monsieur et que vous
pourriez m'aider à sortir de ma voiture
je suis bloqué dans ma voiture depuis ce
matin c'est une fusion voit ce geste est
pas un peintre
et du plateau tu les gagnes tu peux pas
sortir de la voiture ma gueule ou quoi
tu veux pas sortir là non je ne peux pas
sortir je suis incapable c'est physique
j'arrive à tirer une question une
cinglée d'eau [ __ ]
moi je vous préviens je vais au cap
ferret j'habitais à bout je vais au cap
ferret
aux événements et à mon frère s'est fait
renverser par un nom qu moi je le but et
et vous une ex mari est tombé amoureux
de ma meilleure amie quelle grosse [ __ ]
très grosse pubs
et bars
qui sait si david il est petit il va
t'aider iphone une à deux séances par
semaine pendant désert nouveau challenge
apte à une heure où je te bute pas
parlez moi de votre père il fait quoi
agriculteur mais jean paul rault de
celui de madame
[Musique]
2 et 3 alors par le truc là ça prend du
temps
vous pensez qu'il a besoin de vous et
juste pour rire quand on est paumé qu'on
fait n'importe quoi
[Musique]
il est sûr de mode plus
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas un hasard s'il a débarqué dans
ma voiture
[Musique]
m
plus quoi s'y plaît c'est ça ton
problème en fait tu es tout le temps
négatifs
[Musique]